So now let's take a quick break and have a recap
of what we just discussed. I want you to think about what
are the major causes of the software crisis. I'm going to provide you
a set of possibilities and I would like for you to mark
all that apply. Was that increasing costs of computers? Was it increasing
product complexity, or maybe the lack of programmers? Or was it, instead,
this slow programmers productivity growth? The
lack of funding for software engineering
research? The rise in demand for software? And finally, was it maybe
the lack of caffeine in software
development organizations? Again, mark all that apply.